but there was still unfinished business
and I wanted to fight to ensure that the
changes that we had promised and the new
and stronger Scottish Parliament that we
said we would deliver I wanted to be
absolutely certain that these changes
would happen and that the new Parliament
would be in place before I make the
decision to stand down as a member of
parliament and even after a week of
speculation when it's a strange
experience to read your obituary even
before you've retired today I have my
say tomorrow the newspapers will have
their say and then history will have its
say but it is a strange experience to
read them before you retire but I'm in
no doubt that it's the right thing to do
a new person with new ideas and new
vision new insight new energy to
represent this constituency and to stand
for us as the labour party at the next
general election and we are not leaving
five it is London that I'm leaving and
for the avoidance of any doubt I'm not
going back to Westminster not to the
house of commons after the general
election and not to the house of lords
it is faith where our home is and where
we will be where our children Jean and
Fraser who are here tonight are happily
at school and it's from Fife where I
would do the new and extended work as
the United Nations Special Envoy on
global education